on peut leur en a parlé de politique si
elle est vraie la semaine dernière
c'était la veille des élections
municipales elle pouvait pas pour pas
influencer les électeurs
fichtre ça veut dire que si j'avais dit
des trucs le ps se serait pas pris une
branlée voilà tout ça
enfin franchement si le csa voulais
vraiment que les électeurs soient pas
influencés il devrait censurer toutes
les allocutions télé de françois
hollande oui
là on gagnerait quelques points bon ce
qui concerne les résultats à paris entre
nkm et hidalgo alors bon ça va pas
beaucoup intéressé pourtant ça parlait
que de cul
ah oui c'est vrai c'est ul crèche
universités logement
et pour la ville des célibataires c'est
vrai que c'est vachement excitant at
envie de participer aux trucs donc
comment te dire mon tant que célibataire
qu'on ouvre trois crèches
supplémentaires ou qu'on mette de
l'arsenic dans les repas des cantines
scolaires
moi ça change pas ma vie quoi non c'est
vraiment ça change pas ma vie alors
l'autre gros enjeux de ces élections est
ce que le fl à percer sa salle à part à
terre
leluc mantes-la-ville beaucaire quand tu
vois le monde et ville on dirait le
guide du routard des communes engloutis
par des barrages edf théo en voie d'être
accordée à la 4g quoi vraiment le truc
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas le complémentaire annonce is
right arrivé je veux dire que cogolin
qui tousse et wall street qui s'enrhume
en fait claire
résultat démission de jean marc ayrault
c'est curieux c'est légal une démission
après deux ans de préavis
hu
[Applaudissements]
alors
moi on va raconter un peu la scène
comment ça s'est passé en fait il ya
jean marc ayrault il est venu là dit
voilà françois je démissionne et
hollande a dit [ __ ] t'as de la chance
en tout cas pour une fois hollande a
pris une décision rapide ont deux jours
douche comprise quoi le truc il a jamais
fait ça avant mais pourtant moi j'aime
bien quand ils moi j'aime bien quand il
prend son temps c'est quand il fait le
mec un peu à l'aise quand il fait beau
ou moche moi j'aime être l'homme
invisible puis là je vais baisser les
charges peuvent augmenter les impôts
mais je vais les baisser parce qu'après
on sait pas et peut-être ça va marcher
opinons ça marche pas alors on va faire
pack de responsabilité moi je sais pas
ce que c'est mon verra dans cinq ans
mais tu vois le mec sera à l'aise dans
ces stan smith il est là à la fraîche
détendue du skate beau gosse poutine
depuis sa salle à là on en rit on en rit
bien sûr on en rit parce qu'il faut rire
malheureusement qui gère pas un pays de
65 millions de personnes parce que
sinon ça serait vraiment intéressant
irresponsable et
alors qu'il a mis pour dynamiter tout ça
vous en avez parlé valsaient ramires
police française que
non mais les gens n'ont aucune
imagination quoi comme on a eu un mot
aux manettes bas pour changer on va
mettre un dur voilà où ça vous en avez
assez du mec sous méthadone bas je vous
en débarrasser je met le mexique au
poids la
voilà
la france en ce moment il me fait penser
à une meuf qui sort d'une séance de
sophrologie et qui enchaîne direct avec
un gang bang
[Applaudissements]
alors donc bon valls enfin premier
ministre premier choc duflot ne reste
pas au gouvernement
mais qu'est ce qu'on va devenir
maintenant virer duflot c'est peut-être
le premier geste écologique de vals
haddaoui
[Applaudissements]
grand monde c'est bien ça faut qu'il
réussisse au québec 6 non mais c'est
vrai est ce qu'on peut vraiment dénigrer
un homme qui dans les pires heures de la
république s'est levé et a eu le courage
de dire non à léonard da non
pas à vals petit français de sangria
mêlée
ramires police française pardon
[Applaudissements]
mais faut qu'il fasse attention non je
m'inquiète pour lui parce qu'il est seul
dans gouvernement il n'a pas un pote à
lui il est vraiment dirait une caserne
ukrainienne en prime est
évidemment nouveau premier ministre du
nouveau gouvernement après les jupettes
les valseuses
fallait changer de gouvernement ça c'est
sûr c'est sûr que l'ancien toute façon
c'était un gouvernement de puces ou quoi
c'est vrai bien sûr et je le prouve
trente-huit membres
19h19 femmes 22 mois après pas une qui
soit tombée enceinte
tu m'étonnes qu'ils défendent le mariage
alors pas belle la vie et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus